oh these guys the most flattering voices
I am sung one show aka Pro CD and I'm
here to dub BuzzFeed clips I haven't
seen these I don't know if this is gonna
be funny there's no promises whatever
let's just do it here we go
[Music]
surprising drunk girls with puppies I'm
gonna name this one peaches my mommy
lets me have two puppies for breakfast
god damn it put me down put me down hmm
just gotta open sorry
something smells like well Americans try
some strumming for the first time I
don't know what the that is Oh jeepers
oh oh no siree whoa I'm just gonna focus
on that guy oh Jesus Mary Joseph Oh
golly gee that actually fit pretty well
I hate ladylike women try doing makeup
without mirrors stop the wheel Charlotte
starts hey right now I'm stabbing with
myself in the demon world
here he goes go on Marcia I get myself
ready for a date with a car when you're
dating car it's gotta be
so how's it going in the demon realm oh
you know eternal suffering damnation and
getting roasted on spits you know the
usual
one minute you did it congratulations
you get to live please turn the light on
for us please don't please don't do it
demon hey demon we met a guy named the
father Thomas and he was a priest
actually my name wasn't father Thomas it
was father Daryl and I really wish to
remember my name well the thing is thing
was darkness demon if it was Thomas then
turn on the flesh
[Music]